[Musica]
erano
perché o meno così il 6 gennaio 2021
mentre noi finivamo il torrone perché
tanto eravamo in lockdown oppure
spacchetta vamo l'albero o smontavamo il
presepio negli stati uniti al congresso
degli stati uniti si celebrava un
momento topico era il passaggio dalla
presidenza trump alla presidenza byte e
quel momento in molti lo ricordiamo per
che quell'edificio è lì l'edificio del
congresso degli stati uniti dove si
doveva celebrare quel momento quel
passaggio
l'edificio è stato travolto assaltato da
migliaia di persone
e quali sono entrate per porte e
finestre e l'hanno svuotato si sono
portate via medaglioni suppellettili
computer libri eccetera
ed è stato un momento particolare ora
gli stati uniti non hanno una storia
come quella italiana una cultura base
sulla quale possono posare le proprie
spalle come noi su dante o su galileo
non possono basarsi sulla corona inglese
o sulla magna carta hanno un documento
la fondazione stessa della loro società
e la democrazia e la costituzione
americana che la cementa il congresso
degli stati uniti non è un edificio
pubblico è un tempio insieme sacro della
liturgia laica della democrazia
americana è quello era un momento
particolare per noi anche perché era il
momento in cui si vedeva il passaggio da
un uomo più importante nel mondo all
uomo che l'avrebbe sostituito appunto il
presidente degli stati uniti e tra le
tante figure che hanno occupato quelle
sale un ace rimasta in mente anche
perché era un italo americano
questa figura che è passata al nome col
nome dello sciamano vediamo l'immagine
è difficile dimenticare un personaggio
con un copricapo a forma di elmo
vichingo con una specie di scialle di
pelo sul sul petto villoso ebbene tanti
ricordano lo si amano per la sua
particolarità
perché era singolare centrico come tanti
però io mi permetto di dissentire c'è
un'altra ragione per la quale dovremmo
ricordarlo e rivediamo l'immagine
quell'uomo quel giorno aveva in mano
questo così come l'avevano tantissimi
che hanno devastato quella quelle sale
cos'è successo perché il tempio della
democrazia fosse invaso il nome della
democrazia perché pensare di assaltare
gli stati uniti il nome degli stati
uniti
cosa ha portato le persone a pensare che
la democrazia dovesse essere salvata in
un momento in cui tutti sanno che cos'è
la democrazia è la portata di chiunque
ciascuno di noi può avere il mondo non
solo in mano sotto i propri occhi ma
nelle proprie tasche grazie allo
smartphone non accediamo continuamente a
miriadi di fonti di informazioni non
raccogliamo continuamente news da
chiunque non rilanciamo opinioni e idee
di altri la democrazia quando incontra
il digitale non si rafforza forse non
sempre quello che accade e sta accadendo
negli stati uniti più che da noi ma già
da noi il 50 per cento della popolazione
segue costantemente in social media il
20 per cento usa i social media come la
maggio parte la maggior parte delle
informazioni di cui ha bisogno
ebbene tutto questo funziona perché il
social media funzionano ci piacciono di
più ci assomigliano perché ci danno una
restituzione della realtà che
assomigliano ea quello che ci interessa
di più
a quello che ci piace che ci corrisponde
che ci conforta che rafforza le nostre
idee
questo però ha un lato più oscuro questo
filtro che ci consente di godere dei
social media contemporaneamente lascia
fuori quello che non ci piace quello che
ci porterebbe c disgusterebbe un pc con
chi ci costringerebbe a cambiare
l'effetto è che il 50 per cento delle
informazioni nei social media porta a
fonti false perché accade questo perché
noi normalmente leggiamo e rilanciamo
informazioni eccezionali singolari che
hanno più probabilità di essere false il
risultato
una notizia falsa sei volte la
penetrabilità di una notizia vera nella
società che succede quando così tante
persone hanno idee diverse ma vivono in
contesti diversi che non hanno nulla a
che fare l'una con l'altra
cosa succede quando non c'è alcuna
relazione tra una bolla perché vengono
chiamate così bollo camere di ecco non
hanno alcuna consonante ad una trovata
con l'altra non si confrontano non
scambiano idee
beh gli stati uniti avevano una
bellissima espressione che era quella
del libero mercato delle idee
l'idea di una democrazia se volete molto
mercantilista e consumeristica nella
quale le idee si confrontano perché sono
in uno spazio aperto nel quale ciascuno
di noi può acquistare o lasciare quello
che non piace oppure paragonare le varie
proposte
qui il paragone alfinito non ci sono più
varie opinioni che vengono riversati in
un contesto comune ma diversi contesti
che non filtrano più l'uno con l'altro
delle idee e spesso si rafforzano nelle
proprie convinzioni
ora ciascuno di noi è convinto ed è
giusto che la democrazia funziona con il
consenso se la maggior parte delle
persone d'accordo su una certa idea
quella diventerà legge è normale la
democrazia funziona con il consenso ma
la democrazia ha bisogno del dissenso ha
necessità del di sesso come l'ossigeno
c'è bisogno che le nostre idee vengano
paragonate con quelle degli altri che
noi ci lasciamo urtare da quello che non
ci piace ci disgusta che non vorremmo
sentire perché fa sgretolare le nostre
opinioni su di noi e sul moto ma questo
non ci ha precluso dagli algoritmi
certo gli algoritmi ci conoscono bene
che una settantina di like sono in grado
di sapere qual è il nostro gruppo etnico
le opinioni politiche o le preferenze
sessuali ma abbiamo la possibilità di
cercare quello che non ci piace questo
possiamo farlo possiamo usare i nostri
telefonini per cercare quello che ci
provoca qualcuno ha detto
certe volte o delle opinioni che non
condivido opinioni che non condividiamo
ne abbiamo bisogno
e giunto il momento di andarsela a
cercare